e aí
[Música]
o d-fine vida minha história vou contar
eu preciso de um jeito minha natureza se
transformar nascida da existência de uma
força interior requisitada pela luta de
ser quem eu sou no início foi loucura
não tropecei o tempo correu as estradas
uma vida de temor cair daí mesma na bem
nas águas opressor noite intensa
escuridão e muito favor
se transforma transparência garota que
faz sentir pensar de que se é hoje é uma
incoerência e falta de hipócrita no
reino da insistência transforma
transparência garota que faz sentir
pensar você tem fiel hoje é uma
incoerência sobre publicar no reino das
essências do frio na pele agora era todo
desamor amigos antes que me amavam hoje
trilham com rancor minha família
corrompida pela ideia fica você aquilo
que nasce e não que você cria a
realidade é rainha que matou o rei que
amava sendo um ela mesma assassina de
testada perdoe minha família toda essa
revolução mas a mulher que eu sou não
aguentava a prisão as aves no cativeiro
é ignorância eu quebrei a correntes com
sabedoria esperando a natureza é mãe
universo é pai meu corpo santuário minha
vida meus ideais não façam mal ao corpo
a aparência que tem um expresso a minha
essência infeliz eu era cheia de certeza
falso teatro e aplausos da nobreza
transforma transparência garoto aqui
quais sentir e pensar você tem fiel hoje
é uma incoerência sobre pop tá no reino
da existência transforma transparência
garoto aqui vai ser que pensar você tem
que é hoje é uma incoerência souza
pipoca entrar no reino das nascentes
transforma a transparência garota que
faz a gente pensar tem que ser hoje o
maior coerência sou hipócrita no reino
das aparências
e aí
oi bom dia oi gente eu sou a cantora de
moraes esse é o meu balé essa essa
música se chama dama hipócrita é uma
música que foi me presenteada por uma
filósofa transexual chamada a pena de
voar e foi um prazer fazer essa música
ela trouxe a dor dela da transição e eu
trouxe a minha dor de uma sobrevivência
de violência contra a mulher eu tô aqui
viva fora dos padrões me sentindo
maravilhosa cantando para vocês e
mostrando que quem faz o padrão somos
nós e independente do padrão que a
sociedade quer nos impor eu não aceito
eu sou linda só gostosa maravilhosa sou
capaz o potente
e eu posso fazer o que eu quiser
e aí
oi e para mostrar um pouquinho dessa
nova fase desse novo trabalho eu vou
apresentar para vocês o compositor que
tá trabalhando comigo nesse trabalho tão
lindo e ele vai cantar uma canção comigo
que se chama lua vem davi menezes
em palmas para o davi é
[Aplausos]
e não é doido é
a lua é brilho e-mail escuridão da noite
iluminada cururu somente do na lua de
frente para a lua deixa você nua sabe
que a saudade do seu corpo é a verdade
nua e crua cansei de prender os olhos
contigo aquele jeitinho que a gente sabe
que ele fica comigo que eu te dou certo
outra 5 estrelas de frente para o mar
deitadinha comigo vendo luar e quer uma
aqui ó ontem muito mais que amanhã te
quero mais fugir e vem ficar comigo para
sempre pular
eu abrir meus customizações iluminadas
[Música]
luar é preciso ir meu escuridão da noite
iluminada falso quando não enxergo
escuro
é somente do na lua brincar lua deixo
você boa sabe com saudade do seu corpo é
verdade não lembro antes de prender os
dois pontinhos naquele dia que a gente
sabe ele fica comigo que eu te dou são
todas estrelas de frente pro mar
metadinha comigo vendo o luar te quero
muito mais que amanhã hoje
e vem ficar comigo para sempre voar a
brilho e meu escuridão da noite
iluminadas buzz quando não enxergo no
escuro somente do na lua e
de louis wain brilho em meio à escuridão
da noite ilumina meus passos todo eu não
enxergo escuro somente dona lua
[Música]
é burro é
em palmas para o davi beleza obrigada
davi
[Aplausos]
e essa música que a gente vai cantar
agora que eu vou cantar agora se chama
linda e afrontosa foi a primeira música
que eu escrevi para o meu cd e foi
justamente para valorizar e enaltecer a
minha forma de pensar em questão de ser
mulher negra gorda e mesmo a sociedade
tentando empurrar a gente para baixo eu
quis mostrar que eu sou gorda eu sou
negra eu sou linda eu sou afrontosa
independente de qualquer coisa eu sou
potente eu sou capaz e eu estou aqui
hoje de frente para vocês livre
[Aplausos]
em que momento eu vivi tudo bagunçado
precisando de espaço precisava tanto meu
responde socorrer o tempo fez as pazes
com o espelho hoje eu tô querendo mais
hoje eu tô querendo mais fiz as pazes
com o espelho não me sábado mais ficou
linda afrontosa coifa sai da frente e
segura quero ver quanto tempo viatura
hyundai afrontosa miúda e afrontosa
estou chegando diferente balançando e
a rosa
[Música]
e aí
e sai da frente e segura quero ver
quanto tempo viatura eu dai afrontosa
pendray afrontosa estou chegando
diferente balançando tá ficando
quentinho daí a prosa vida e ação tosa
em quando mundo vencem me cobrir eu só
sorrir e quando você pensa existir
existir um
e sai da frente e segura quero ver
quanto tempo miniatura linda e afrontosa
linda e afrontosa vou chegando diferente
fala usando tá ficando bem linda e
aprovada e daí a pronto
[Música]
o meu pai hoje eu sou querendo mais
riquezas para tô mais pronto tô em paz
e foi um prazer gente muito obrigada até
a próxima
e aí